he seemed incredibly confident and
prepared and I know everyone everyone
here so excited
that's a fresh-faced Megan Markos
surprising a smart works client ahead of
her job interview the charity shared the
clip on their social media accounts on
Wednesday but the video chat actually
happened back in March
just days before Megan and her hubby
Prince Harry's royal exit so what
excites you about this internship I'm
just an opportunity to see something
beyond psychology and the application of
psychology in the real world because as
much as I enjoy learning about it at a
level kind of seeing it in the workplace
or seeing how it could be applied in the
workplace is something that really
interests me so yeah great I think
you're gonna be fantastic in the video
Megan offers career advice and praises
the young job seeker able to call in and
tell you best of luck and my fingers are
crossed for you really you know there's
so much going on in the world right now
just to be such a beacon of hope and
focusing on on getting through it and
all the positivity yes and your way to
make sure that you can get on the other
side of this too and have such a great
opportunity there the young woman also
applauded Megan for her work as patron
of smart works a role that the Duchess
has held since January 2019 oh thank you
so much for making this whole thing
possible through smart works and through
new championing something like this to
empower women it's just it's amazing
that's very plain of work
oh my goodness support them you see how
how great they do and yeah and really
how many people they help right and
that's what it's all fast
basically it was a total love fest but
I've been really proud to be able to be
their patron the uk-based charity helps
women like the client Megan spoke with
find employment through job interview
training and free professional clothing
six weeks ago they moved to a virtual
service amid the corona virus pandemic
in their Instagram caption the charity
revealed that they've already delivered
200 hours of support since making the
transition
[Music]
last fall Megan launched a capsule
collection for SmartWORKS
that included professional pieces from a
variety of different designers and
brands for women interviewing to rejoin
the workforce as women it is a hundred
percent our responsibility I think to
support enough lift each other to
champion each other as we aim to succeed
to not set each other set each other up
for failure but instead to really be
there rallying around each other and say
I want to help you
of course Megan has been championing
women for years that's a testament to
you and is that it's just inspired
people earlier this month the Dutchess
participated in a zoom call with five
women involved with London's hub
community kitchen and she and Harry have
wasted no time getting involved in their
new community of Los Angeles they've
been spotted volunteering with Project
Angel Food several times throughout the
pandemic they know the couple would like
to sit still and they faded waste much
time getting to work delivering food
parcels to vulnerable people in the city
who can't get out to shop